JEFF: Hi everybody.
My name is Jeff Bush and
I'm an engineering manager
on the Android Auto team.
So great to see so
many people here.
I hope people didn't
get too sunburned today.
So we're going to talk about a
few things in today's session.
First I'm going to spend
a few minutes talking
about where we are today
and what we're working on.
Then a few of my
colleagues are going
to come up and do
some short demos,
but the majority
of this session is
going to be a deep dive into how
to bring your apps to Android
Auto.
In 2014 we launched Android
Auto with our partners
in the Open Automotive
Alliance to create
a platform for connected
services in the car.
In the two years since we've
gained a lot of momentum.
We now have 40
manufacturers signed up
to support Android
Auto and there
are over 100 models
of cars on the road
today that use Android Auto.
By the end of the
year we're expecting
to double this number to 200
and support every major car
manufacturer.
And developers are
flocking to the platform.
We currently have
hundreds of apps available
and more are coming every day.
So I want to take a
minute to say thank you
to all the developers who
have supported Android Auto.
We've also recently
launched Android Auto
in 19 new countries including
Brazil, Russia, and India
which brings us to 30 countries
and more are on the way.
We're really excited about
how far the platform has come
and we're even more
excited about the future.
We've gotten a lot of great
feedback from our users
and I'm pleased to say that
the three most requested
features are coming soon.
The first is OK Google.
Android Auto already supports
a rich voice interface,
but being able to initiate
commands hands-free
is a natural for the car.
So we're bringing OK Google
hotwording to Android Auto.
The second is Ways.
As someone who commutes
every day in Silicon Valley,
I'm pretty excited about this.
[APPLAUSE] Ways has
an active community
of millions of users sharing
real time traffic and accident
information to save
time on the commute.
And Waysers have been very vocal
about Android Auto support.
So we've been working with
Ways to make that happen.
I think they've
done an awesome job
and you can actually see it
in action in our demo cars
in the sandbox
right over that way.
The third is wireless.
We think Android Auto
is a great experience,
but wouldn't it be even
better if you could use it
without even having to take
your phone out of your pocket?
So the good news is that we're
working with our manufacturing
partners to bring
support for wireless
to their WiFi enabled cars.
So these are three new
exciting new features.
There are many other
smaller improvements
that we're working on, but
we can't ignore the fact
that there are over
a billion drivers
on the road who don't yet have
cars that support Android Auto.
We know that many drivers are
already using Android phones
in their car dock for
turn by turn navigation
and media streaming.
We think we can make that
experience easier and safer
by letting people use Android
Auto on their phone screen
while docked.
So coming soon Android
Auto will give access
to the same features, voice
enabled media, messaging,
and navigation right on the
phone screen using an interface
that's designed for driving.
Paco will be up on
stage to tell us
more about it in a few minutes.
We also have this
running in our sandbox
and I'd recommend
checking that out as well.
This opens up Android Auto
to a huge number of new users
and that's a great thing
for developers too.
So we're excited about
bringing Android Auto
to old cars and new, but
what about the future?
A trend that we're seeing is
cars with larger screens, fully
digital instrument clusters,
and cellular connectivity,
but to get the
innovation we've seen
on the web and smartphones,
we need a platform
and more importantly,
we need an ecosystem.
In fact, many manufacturers
have recognized this
and are already choosing Android
Auto for their IVI operating
system, but they have
to do a lot of work
to adapt it to an
in-cabin experience.
So we're putting automotive
support into mainline Android
to make a great platform
for built-in infotainment.
This includes support for
vehicle [? networks, ?]
HVAC, and infotainment user
interface and built-in apps.
Being built on Android,
it supports everything
that makes Android great like
multi-user and multitasking
and it will be
completely free and open
source, part of the Android
open source project.
In fact, in the Android end
release coming later this year,
we will include many of
these features already.
We're really excited to work
with our car manufacturing
partners to bring Android
to their future cars.
And in our sandbox
we have a concept car
that we've built with Qualcomm
showing off this technology.
That's one I would
definitely recommend
you check out although there's
a bit of a line right now.
But most importantly,
we're working
to ensure that apps built for
Android Auto work seamlessly
on our built-in
infotainment systems.
So there's a lot of
cool stuff in the works.
And with that, I'd like to
hand it over to Paco, Vincent,
and Victor to show you some
of demos of some of the things
I've talked about.
PACO: Thank you, Jeff.
Thank you.
It's good to see so
many of you here today.
It helps that it's air
conditioned in here.
It's pretty hot out.
So I'm Paco Galanes and
I'm an engineering lead
with Android Auto.
As Jeff mentioned before, we're
expanding the Android Auto
platform to create
new experiences
for existing drivers by
expanding the Android
platform into the car-- sorry,
by bringing the experience
that we've shown you in the car
directly into the phone screen.
We're also expanding
Android directly, natively
into the car.
And that is the concept car
that Jeff already announced.
I'm going to now give you a demo
of how this all works together
and show some of the
features that Jeff announced.
All right.
So we have Vincent
here and he is showing
the [? desktop head ?] unit.
This is a tool that all
developers have available
and it emulates how
the car screen works
once you plug your phone in.
All right.
So once you [? plug ?] in, you
launch into the home screen.
And that gives you access
to tasks that you may
perform right to get started.
We have suggested destinations.
We know where you are, your
location, your time of day.
So we can tell you,
you may want to start
navigating to work today.
And all this, of course,
uses the same Google smarts
that we use all
throughout the platform.
For those of you not familiar
with the platform already let's
do a quick walk through.
So the activity at the
bottom of the screen
gives you access to common
applications that you
will be using while driving.
We have media.
Of course you have
access to your dialer
and your common contacts.
That wasn't it.
Contacts, dialer-- there it is.
And of course, you have also
access to navigation and Maps.
All right, perfect.
Let's go back to the home.
Notice that the whole
screen is a lot bigger
than any other application that
runs on your phone and this
is because this is
the sign for driving.
You need to tap that
screen while it's
running at arm's length
on your dashboard.
All right.
Let's go into navigation now.
Of course we have
integrated Google Maps
with all the great navigation
tools that you're all
familiar with but
under the platform,
we're working on also
integrating Ways,
as Jeff announced, which is a
tremendously popular navigation
app as you all are aware.
Let's switch to it.
There it is.
All right.
Whew!
Vincent is going
to pick directions.
We're going to the
beach later today
so he's getting a head start.
He has the directions right
there in his favorites.
And off he goes.
Great.
As with Google Maps,
the same applies here.
We display the next turn
right there in this interface
but you also recognize some
of the Ways specific features
in the screen, reporting
an incident right there.
Great.
We've also integrated messaging,
by the way, though it's mostly
a voice-driven experience.
And speaking of
voice, of course,
we've enabled most
of the common tasks
that you can perform
while in the platform
while using Android
Auto via voice.
All right.
Let me show you how messaging
actually works in the platform.
I'm going to text him telling
him that I'll meet him later.
Of course he gets a
quick notification.
Messaging is a
notification-driven
application.
In the alert we show
you enough information
to know if you really
need to take it or not,
but it goes away and it's always
available through the home
screen.
He can decide to
listen to the message
when it's safe to do so.
All right.
ANDROID VOICE:
Here's the message.
Finishing my presentation
at Google I/O.
Let me know when you get there.
Now he could use voice to
send me a quick message
or we always give you a
pre-canned customizable message
that you can just tap and let
me know that I'm driving now,
don't disturb me.
Note that this works with many
messaging [? works ?] and not
only SMS.
We have many applications
have already integrated.
Chances are that your favorite
application is already
in the platform.
If you haven't
integrated your app yet,
we'll show you
later how to do so.
Thank you, Vincent.
Let's switch to the
video down below
and let's see what
Victor has for us there.
All right.
So that is a testing
harness for the concept car
that we have out there in
the sandbox, the Maserati.
Come see it later
if you get a chance.
The concept has two screens,
both powered by Android.
The instrument cluster right
above the steering wheel,
of course, and the bigger
infotainment system
to the right.
Very good.
Because of the
larger screen that we
have available here in
instrument infotainment screen,
we can make use of the
multi-window features
of Android [? M ?] to display
more than one application
at the same time.
You notice at the bottom
we have the climate control
application.
Gets hotter today, so
let's cool it down.
In the middle, we have the
currently running application,
right now navigation and maps.
He's already going
to meet us later.
And at the top we have
a permanent screen
where we can show you
other running applications,
other running activities.
And we can also,
of course, show you
some content coming
from Google Now
or other notifications
from the system.
All right, let's focus on
the cluster for a minute.
Very traditional-looking cluster
with a fuel gauge, speedometer,
and something new there which is
the next turn from Google Maps.
That area can also be used
for other notifications
like in this case, the next
track from the media player.
Let's move back to the
big screen, please.
All right.
Now here we see how Victor
switched to the media player
as the main application.
And notice-- I don't
know if you noticed
that-- the navigation [? car ?]
went on top to the notification
area, to the permanent
area right there.
Perfect, thank you.
For the media
section he has access
to all auto-enabled
applications,
media applications that
are already out there.
Whatever is in his
car, he'll pick one.
Great.
Media applications
have two main screens.
We saw the first one with
the playback controls.
Those playback controls are a
standard-- play, pause, skip.
Some of them are customizable.
And, of course, we
have a second screen
which is showing now which is
the menu for browsing content
where applications show what's
available for the user to pick.
We recommend that we keep the
hierarchies kind of shallow
and that we try to surface
on top personalized content--
frequents, favorites, etc.
So it's less distracting.
All right.
I hope you can hear that.
PODCAST: This can
help anyone get really
good at just about anything--
PACO: I thought he was
going to play salsa
but he is on a podcast today.
All right.
Victor will talk to
you later about how
to integrate media
applications into the platform
if you haven't done so already.
Thank you, Victor.
Let's move to the
phone area here.
Great.
Let me show you how the third
Android Surface will work.
It's Android Auto on the screen.
No new car needed.
All I have to do is bring up
the Android Auto application
from the icon and here I
am in the Android Auto home
screen, adapted to the
screen in my phone.
This should look very
familiar to you already.
I can also set Android
Auto to auto-launch
when it detects the
Bluetooth device in my phone
when I turn it on, for instance.
From the home
screen, I have access
to the same suggested
destinations
we talked about before.
It's Android Auto,
it's the same platform.
I also have ongoing
activities like media.
And it can show me missed
messages or missed calls
that I may want to return.
All right, so from
the media card,
I can always go
to the media app.
Again, I have access to all
the media applications that
are running on my phone that
are Android Auto enabled-- books
on tape, books, podcasts,
several music apps.
Let me pick one.
And when we launch
the app, I can
start playing where I left off.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PACO: But I also have access
to the full menu just one
swipe away.
By the way, the customizable
controls are also here.
All right.
Another thing that
I wanted to show you
quickly is how messaging
works in this screen.
So Vincent is going
to tell me when
he's up here that he's already
in Santa Cruz waiting for me.
It's taking him a little
long to get there today.
All right.
So here's the message.
Notice that the notifications
in the phone screen
are a little larger than usual.
They are adapted for the smaller
screen size so I can tap them
while I'm driving.
As we saw before, I don't
have to tap that notification
to listen to it.
It's always in my home screen.
ANDROID VOICE 1:
Here's the message.
Hey I'm here now.
You can press the voice
button and say reply.
PACO: Of course, I could
try to reply with voice,
but, as always, the auto
reply message is there
and I can just tell him,
I'm driving right now,
I'll catch you later.
All right.
The last thing I
wanted to show you
is how the power of
voice integration
works with Android Auto.
I don't know if this will
work in the environment.
You guys are kind of
quiet so I'm going to try.
Let me see.
Navigate to Santa Cruz.
ANDROID VOICE 1:
Santa Cruz, USA.
All right.
PACO: All right.
ANDROID VOICE 1: You should
reach your destination
by 7:32 PM.
PACO: Great.
So I'm navigating.
And, of course, the
next turn is always
available from the home
screen so I don't miss a turn
no matter what I'm doing.
ANDROID VOICE 1: Turn right
onto Bill Graham Parkway.
PACO: Let me stop
this for a second.
All right, so I hope that
this quick demo gave you
an idea of how the
platform works together.
The next thing that
we're going to do
is-- let's go back
to the slides.
Perfect.
We're going to go into
more detail about how
you integrate your apps into
the Android Auto platform.
We're going to talk
about messaging
and we're going to
talk about media.
And remember that if
you've already integrated,
it will run seamlessly on
both phone and car screens.
We use the same interfaces
across all three surfaces.
If you haven't integrated
yet, stay around
and Victor is going to tell us
how to integrate with media.
VICTOR: Thanks, Paco.
Hi, I'm Victor.
I'm a software engineer
on the Android Auto team
and I'm here to talk
about media apps.
There are a couple things
I want to focus on today.
First of all, we'll look at
how to make your media app
compatible with
Android Auto then
I'll offer some tips
and best practices
to help you provide a
great media experience
inside of a vehicle.
So as you saw
earlier in the demo,
media content can show up
in many different forms
in various Android Auto devices.
On the left here, we
have our media facet
which is a templated
UI experience where
the user can control
playback and also we
offer browsing capabilities.
On the other hand, media
content can appear more
passively such as a card
inside of our overview stream
or as a notification inside
of our instrument cluster.
I just want to point
out again, across all
these different
surfaces-- whether it's
a phone screen or a car
screen-- the developer only
needs to implement the necessary
APIs for service just once
and when that's done
Android Auto would
do all the heavy
lifting to ensure
a safe and engaging experience
across all these scenarios.
All right, let's dive into code.
So first of all, we need
to do a bit of set-up
because we want Android Auto
to be able to find your app.
So here in our
Android manifest file,
I point to a secondary XML
file named Auto App Descriptor.
And inside the
Auto App Descriptor
I say that this is
an automotive app
and it is of the type media.
So this really lets us know
that your app can provide
audio content for auto devices.
Once we can find
you, you'll need
to implement a service-- in this
case, the MediaBrowserService.
The MediaBrowserService
does two things.
First of all, it provides
a content hierarchy
which is what we use
to create a content
browser that the user can
then use to find and explore
audio tracks.
At the same time,
the MediaBrowser
should attach a
media session, which
is what we use to control--
or rather remote control--
playback inside your app.
So here is a sample
MediaBrowserService.
As you can see, we're
implementing-- or rather
extending
MediaBrowserService compact
which is available in Support
Library 23.2 and higher.
And of course this will help
your app run on older devices.
There are two methods
that we need to implement
inside the MediaBrowserService.
The first one is the
onGetRoot [? method. ?]
Now this is called to
retrieve the browser
root of your content tree.
This root itself is not
a media item, however,
we use this route to retrieve
a list of media items which
are then used to populate the
top level of our content menu.
Also note that root hints
may be passed to you.
These can include things like
offline, recent, or suggested.
And these are really just
hints that Android Auto wants
to tell you in terms
of what kind of content
you should be sending back.
So try to respect these when
you're exposing your content.
The second method that you
need to [? overwrite ?]
is the onload children call.
Now every Android Auto needs to
display a list of media content
inside of our media app.
This method is
invoked and you will
be passed a parent
ID of the media item
and we expect you to return
a list of its children.
Now let's take a closer look
at this [? onload ?] children
method.
First of all, I want to say if
you are returning media items
try to do so from a cache.
And the reason is, you can
imagine a user is driving down
the highway, they're
listening to some songs
and they want to play
a different playlist
and now, suddenly, your app
needs to go across the network
to download all those songs.
And you can imagine if the
cell signal is not great,
the user is looking at
a screen that's loading
and their eyes are not
on the road anymore.
So not only is this
a bad experience,
it's also not very safe.
So we really recommend you
to cache your media items
as you're creating
the content tree,
so when [? onload ?]
children gets called,
you're able to return the media
items immediately from memory.
Now if you have to
go over the network,
just simply detach
the result object,
set up your asynchronous
tags, and once you're
finished loading
just send it back
through the results object.
So while we're on the subject
of content hierarchies,
let's take a look at some of
the common pitfalls or mistakes
that people tend to make.
So in this example here we have
a media app that can play radio
and it separates it
down into local radio
and further breaks it down
into different genres like jazz
or pop or other types of music.
In this case, the
user has to click
at least three times before they
can reach the first playable
item.
So this deep nesting is
actually not very good
because you can imagine,
again, the user is on the road
and they're tapping
the screen three times
before they can do anything.
So again, in this
case, you should really
try to surface interesting
content or engaging
content higher up in the tree so
that it's available to the user
right away.
The next thing is we've heard a
lot of feedback from our users
that they want to be able to get
to all of their media content
while they are inside the car.
So we're working
on ways for users
to browse through large amounts
of media content, of course,
in a safe manner.
So what does this mean
for the app developers?
What this means is you should
not truncate your content trees
prematurely.
In this example,
the user has finally
gotten to the jazz section
and there's actually
just two stations because
everything else got cut off.
So let's try not to do that.
So the last thing I want to
talk about content browsing.
It's if your data is dynamic--
so for example, you're
a media app that generates
a playlist based on where
the user is or the traffic
conditions then when
that content changes,
you need to notify us
because we can update the
content browser for the user.
And you would do this through
the notify children change
call.
All right.
Now that we've talked
about media browsing,
let's take a look
at media session.
So the media session
serves two purposes.
First it lets you send updates
to us about playback states
or metadata changes.
Also it allows us to
remote control playback
inside your media app.
So here we have our
MediaBrowserService again.
This time let's take a look
at the [? entree ?] method.
Inside of [? on ?] [? create ?]
we instantiate a MediaSession
object.
And the first thing that we
do is we take its SessionToken
and we set it as
the SessionToken
for the MediaBrowserService.
Now this is important because
when Android Auto connects
to your media app, the first
thing it does is the retrieve
this SessionToken and
creates a media controller
object which is then used to
control playback and receive
updates.
Also there is the
media session callback
which we use to handle
a playback event-- which
you will implement to handle
playback events from Android
Auto.
We will take a closer look
at this in the next slide.
And, finally, remember
when everything is done,
release the media session.
This frees up any
system resources
and actually tells
Android Auto that you're
finished playing so we can clean
up any leftover UI elements.
All right so here's our
sample media session callback.
So the methods here
allow the callback
object to handle
various playback events.
You overwrite them as you need.
So for example, if your app
is a streaming radio app then
maybe you don't need the
[? on ?] skip to next button
because that doesn't
make any sense.
So in that case, you
can simply leave that
as the default implementation.
Now in the case of [? an on ?]
play or [? on ?] resume,
you should check if your
media session is active.
If your media session is
not active, set it to active
and this tells Android Auto
that you are in fact playing
and that we can
surface your content
inside of our stream or inside
of our notification area.
Another method I want
to talk about here
is the [? onplay ?]
from media ID.
So this method is invoked when
a user goes through the content
browser, clicks the
playable media item,
and expects something to play.
This method will be invoked and
the media ID will pass it in.
And this media ID
is the same that you
have passed to us through the
media item in the [? onload ?]
children call.
So you can imagine the
media ID should be unique
and it should be
persistent so you
can find the right song to play
when the user clicks on it.
A note about voice support.
So if you want your app to
support command through voice
like play jazz on
my media app, you'll
first need to specify
an intent filter
inside your manifest file.
This basically tells us that
you are able to handle playback
from search.
So when the user issues
the actual command,
we'll launch your app and
the on play from search call
will be invoked.
Now you will be passed both
the query and a set of extras.
So if the query, first
of all, is empty,
you should still try
to play something back
because this tells the user
that your app is responsive
and that their action
has taken place.
Now if the query
is valid, you can
try to parse the query
yourself or you can look
inside the extras and we'll pass
the information such as title,
album, or artist name.
And finally, if you can't
actually find the song,
that's OK.
Just show an error.
Again, this is to tell the user
that your app is responsive.
So now let's look at
some of the updates
that your apps can send
over to Android Auto.
First of all, there is
the metadata object.
This contains things like
title, artist, or album art.
And let's focus a little
on album art here.
As you saw earlier in
the demo, the album art
of the track that's
playing can show up
as the background image of maybe
a 15 inch, [? 4K ?] screen.
In this case, resolution
is really important.
So you can send us that
album art in two ways.
You can send it to us either
through a bitmap or a URI.
I recommend you guys
to do it in a URI
because Android, the
framework, actually scales down
the bitmap to 320 by 320 DP.
So if you want a high resolution
image the URI is the way to go.
So the other state that you can
send us is the playback state.
This tells us things like
if your app is playing,
if it's stopped,
and actions that it
can take-- if it can skip
forward, if it can pause--
and also tells us the
playback position--
how far along in the song
you're currently playing.
A couple of tips here, don't
send us a playback state change
every second if the only
thing that is changing
is the playback position
because we don't use this value
to update the progress bar
instead of our media app.
In fact, you're just
taxing the system
and we're ignoring
these updates.
On a similar note, if your
app is actually stopped,
don't send playback states
unless they're actually
changing because, again,
we're just ignoring them
and you're taxing the system.
Finally, I want to talk
about the buffering state.
This is an interesting
one because when
the user clicks play and you
need to download the song,
you should send the state to us
right away because we can then
tell the user through a
spinner or progress bar
that the track is
being downloaded
because if you don't do that,
your UI will seem somewhat
unresponsive.
And with that I'll hand it over
to Vincent for customizations.
VINCENT: Thanks, Victor.
Hi everyone.
My name is Vincent and
I'm an Engineer Manager
on the Android Auto team.
So with Android
Auto we want media
apps to be able to showcase
the uniqueness their users have
grown to love and
expect in the car.
It's also important
that the user experience
is one that is optimized
and friendly for driving.
And to be honest, this
is a challenging task.
Android Auto itself has
undergone extensive user
studies, driver
distraction testing
in simulators and in
real-life driving scenarios
where minimum contrast ratio,
tap target sizes, glance times,
cognitive load, and
driving performance
are all factored
into its design.
As you can imagine,
this isn't something
that we want or we
think every media
app should have to get right.
In the end we thought
that it was best
for the users and developers to
have an API that abstracts this
out so developers like you can
focus on making your apps great
knowing Android
Auto will provide
an appropriate in-car
user experience.
So in this section,
I'll be walking you
through how you can easily
customize your media
app for Android Auto.
So media playback controls
are the primary interface
for users to control their
media playback experience.
These controls are displayed
throughout Android Auto
and laid out
differently depending
on the surface and the
condition that Android Auto is
running in.
For example, the audio controls
card on the phone screen
might look different
than the audio control
cards on the car
screen and it also
looks different in night
mode versus in day mode.
Again, this isn't
something that your app
needs to be concerned about
since Android Auto will
handle this behind the scenes.
So how do you get your app to
surface the appropriate actions
or the controls for your app?
In the media session
playback state,
remember that your
app is actually
already updating the playback
state for the media session.
Set the supported actions,
via the actions method
in the playback state builder.
The playback state compact
class, if you look into it,
has a defined set
of standard media
action constants
like play, pause,
skip forward, and skip previous.
Let's look at the action skip
to next constant as an example.
Because it's listed
as a supported action,
Android Auto will surface the
button in the controls panel.
When the user interacts
with this button,
the media session's call
back on skip to next API
will get invoked.
A few things to keep
in mind-- remember
to always keep the
supported actions up to date
based on the appropriate
playback state
that the user may be in.
For example, if the user is at
the beginning of the playlist,
it might be a good
idea to remove
the skip to previous action.
We also recommend
that apps always
report all the supported
actions so that the app doesn't
lose any functionality.
Now, what if your
media app supports
additional actions that aren't
defined in the playback state
compact?
For example, maybe a thumbs up.
Well you can create
your own custom action.
A custom action contains a
few things-- an action string.
This is very
specific to your app
and it's unique for
each custom action.
And action label text.
This may be displayed
for accessibility.
A drawable resource.
This is shown in the
actual playback control.
Remember to include
transparency in it
and we also recommend using SVG
so that we can properly display
it in various screen sizes.
And lastly there is also an
extras bundle that is optional.
So when the user interacts
with a custom action playback
control, the on custom
action method of your media
session callback gets invoked.
This is where you can handle
the actual like action.
We also know product
branding is important
for you and we want your app's
branding to show through well
in Android Auto.
So if your app already uses
the material design color
theme like the
color primary color
accent and color primary
dark, Android Auto
will show these colors
in the appropriate places
throughout our UI.
You can also define an
Android Auto specific theme
in your media app by adding a
metadata element in your apps
manifest as shown.
Lastly, Android Auto may show
a media related notification.
For example, when the next
track is being played,
a notification with the
track name will be shown.
So be sure to specify an icon
resource in your manifest so
that your apps icon is also
displayed in the notification.
So that's it.
With a few simple steps you
can customize your media app
with an Android Auto
that works across all the
supported surfaces while
getting a driver-tested user
experience for free.
So next I want to
talk about messaging.
We know that staying
connected to people
that we care about, like
our friends or family,
is very important to all of
us regardless of whether we're
in the car or not.
With driver safety in
mind, it's important
that users can
access their messages
in Android Auto with
minimal distractions
so that drivers can
focus on the road.
We don't think every
messaging app should
be burdened with having to do
extensive driver distraction
testing to achieve this goal.
So with messaging, we've
taken a similar approach
as we have with the media.
We have an API that abstracts
out these things so that you
don't have to worry about and
focus on getting the messaging
experience right.
This is just a recap
of how messaging works.
As Paco demoed earlier,
it's pretty straightforward.
We have a notification
that appears when it comes
and then there's a
messaging card that
remains in the overview screen.
The API quite simple.
It's actually built on top
of Android notifications
which is something I'm sure
your app is already using.
So when an incoming
message arrives,
your messaging app
already will notify
Android of the notification.
Now if your notification is
extended with CarExtender,
Android Auto will be able
to receive the notification
and display the
notification to the user.
When the user issues a
read command via voice,
Read PendingIntent gets
sent back to your app.
Similarly, when the user
replies to a conversation,
a Reply PendingIntent
get sent back.
Like media, before you get
Android Auto to recognize
your app for messaging,
make sure you
include the notification usage
in your Android manifest.
OK, so let's dive into the part
of extending your notification
with CarExtender.
The first portion of this
code snippet looks familiar.
The interesting part
that we care about here
is where we extend it
with a CarExtender object.
One tip that I want to pass
on is if your app is actually
checking to see if Android Auto
is present before extending
the notification,
we recommend not
checking for the existence
of the Android Auto package
since that's not very reliable.
Instead, you can use
the UI mode manager
and see if Android Auto
is running in car mode.
So let's look at the
unread conversation object.
First, I think it would
be useful to define
some definitions.
So a message is essentially
just a short length of text
that Android Auto will
read out to the user.
It's best to not make
these messages too long.
A conversation essentially
is a collection
of messages that are grouped
together in some way.
And typically messages between
user and another person
will be a conversation.
So with that-- and an
unread conversation
is actually just a
set of unread messages
for a particular conversation.
OK so what goes inside
this conversation--
this unread conversation.
You can pass any
conversation name.
This is the text
that gets presented
to the user when Android Auto
presents an unread message.
Obviously you pass in
the actual messages.
There might be more than one.
And in this case when
you set the time stamp
for these messages,
include the time stamp
for the most recent message.
There are two remaining
ones, the Read PendingIntent
and the reply action
that we'll dive
into more in the next slides.
Also if there is a message
that only has an image,
we recommend including
a readable all text so
that the user doesn't experience
a broken experience when
reading back through messages.
Also please do think about how
this works for group chats.
We recommend actually
just testing out the flow
and seeing if when the
user is reading back
the message if it's an actual,
if it's a good user experience.
All right.
OK, so the Read
PendingIntent, again,
is PendingIntent that
Android Auto sends
back to your messaging app when
the user has invoked a read
action.
It's creating the Read
PendingIntent is pretty simple.
You create the
intent that you want
the app to that you want
Android Auto to send back
when the user has
completed a read message.
To the primary
things to highlight
is you just want to set
the action string that is
specific to this read action.
Be sure to set the
component because we want
this intent to be explicit.
This way it's
guaranteed that your app
will get the PendingIntent.
And then lastly put the extra--
or put the conversation idea
as an extra in the intent
that you can then later check.
And once you have
that then you can just
wrap it in a PendingIntent.
So receiving this Read
PendingIntent is pretty simple.
In your apps manifest
just have a receiver
that is registered against
the read message action string
that we defined earlier.
And this way when the Read
PendingIntent is sent back
to your app, the
appropriate receiver--
the appropriate broadcast
receiver is invoked.
And then the on
received callback,
this is where you can
process the intent
and handle the read
message and event.
So the last part is
the reply action.
I'll kind of just
glance over this.
Again, this is sent when
there is a reply event.
Similar to the
Read PendingIntent,
you create an intent with
the appropriate action
stream that is specific
for the reply message.
And then you can wrap the
intent with Read PendingIntent.
The remote input object
is just passed along
with the Pending Intent
that gets sent back
to your app which will store
the actual string making up
of the user's reply message.
And with that, the broadcast
receiver that you've registered
will get the on receive
callback and then
you can extract the ID and
then the message reply.
One hint or one tip is
when you get this just
don't assume that
the user has read
any unread messages since the
user can actually send replies
out of band.
And then, like media, you
can also customize the look
and feel in this notification,
the CarExtender object.
Again, that was a simple way
of making your messaging app
support Android Auto.
And next I'm going
to invite Paco back.
PACO: All right.
Thank you, Vincent.
Just wanted to conclude
summarizing what I believe
are the main three takeaways
of the presentation.
The first one is that Android
is showing great momentum
in the number of cars
that are supporting
Android Auto, the number of
applications that are already
running on the platform, and
also the number of countries
where it is already available.
The second one is that we're
expanding our regional platform
to give your applications
significantly more reach
by enabling Android Auto on your
phone screen and, of course,
bringing the power of Android
M natively into the car.
And the last point,
still, the same interfaces
will work across
all three surfaces.
Your application will
run in a framework that
has been tested for
driver distraction,
to minimize driver
distraction including
voice integration to power
the most common tasks that you
can perform.
As for next steps, if you're
ready to start implementing,
to start integrating
with the platform,
all the technical details
that we talked about today
are available on these links.
Please join the developer
group, Android Auto Dev.
And if you remember any
link out of this talk,
developerandroid.com/auto.
In the meantime, if
you want to learn more,
you have questions,
come talk to us.
The sandbox is right
behind the big tent
here and check out the
cars from our partners,
check out the concept car
and all of the other ones.
We also have phones there so
you can see how this works.
If you have time and want
to give coding a try,
we also have an Android
Auto-specific code
lab in the code lab section.
If you want to hear
from us in the future,
sign up for news at
android.com/auto.
And I don't think we
have time for Q&A,
but again come talk
to us in the sandbox.
And I don't want to really
take any more time of yours.
Please, it's been a long day.
Go enjoy the concert, go
relax, and thank you very much.